herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einer
trainertyp wünscht challenge einem ich
reagiere heute auf ein video in dem
leute sachen machen wo man einfach
sich die hand vors gesicht schlagen muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich fertig war okay jeder mensch hat
seine eigene technik wie an anderen
menschen küsst aber das ist halt auch
eine technik
[Gelächter]
was ist ganz so was ja hallo ich bin
sehr schön dass mit diesem kompromiss
ist sie abgeschlossen haben und jetzt
gehen wir einfach mal zusammen
ja ja jetzt der bei irgend so einer
datingshow ist und jetzt zum ersten mal
genau sie hier sieht seine liebe
beziehungsweise keine ahnung ob die sich
hier schon mal gesehen haben er hat auf
jeden fall gerade gesagt wenn er
reinkommt wird er direkt auf den kurs zu
gehen und sehr direkt versuchen sie zu
küssen
ich hoffe mal das wird nicht so wie das
andere ab laufen beginnen gesehen haben
also er redet mit ihren aber vielleicht
wird der kuss ja gut egal
[Musik]
was sind was ist falsch mit euch könnt
ihr mal stoppen
hallo heute aus also das ist irgendwann
moderator und er redet mit dem alter
passen pädo es ist ein fernsehmoderator
der fragt die kinder dort ob er eine
umarmung und ein kurs bekommt wenn ich
normal ganz normale tv show na wie heißt
der noch war jakob sartorius dieser da
kommst kurios irgendwie so ein komischer
menschen
also ich glaube die beiden sind ein paar
und die fragen jetzt die oma
der mann mit ihr rummachen darf ein paar
sekunden später
a
[Gelächter]
es tut in meinem herzen weh und überall
wo man fremdscham empfinden kann
ihr müsst euch mal überlegen was da
gerade passiert ist da sitzt ein pärchen
am tisch und die der mann von der frau
fragt einfach so haye dürfte ich
vielleicht mit deiner mutter rummachen
und die frau und die mutter ist auch
dabei also ich bin dabei also sie machen
jetzt eher in kleineren kurs das heißt
es geht der wiwi was unter dem namen
jakob sartorius
keine ahnung von der großmutter gerade
du musst nicht wirklich jetzt mit der
auch noch rum
egal was ist falsch bei euch man online
[Musik]
drei wochen später
ich kann dazu nichts mehr sagen hier ist
eine person bei x-factor ist es glaube
ich also das ist eine sendung wo man ein
besonderes talent besitzen kann und man
hat und das zeigt also wir leben
[Musik]
lasst mich in frieden mit seinen scheiß
dann geht zu so einer show wenn man
denkt ja ich habe wirklich was drauf und
leute sagen wir auch hey das bildest du
dir nicht nur ein du hast wirklich was
auf und dran kommt
[Musik]
ich finde hätte gewinnen müssen hier
haben wir wieder unsere person von
gerade der leidenschaftliche augenringen
da gab es so eigentlich ihre bist du
obama bei der alle winken das kind cool
werden dass obama alle pinken wundervoll
klasse und ja was war das
[Musik]
den menschen hier ist irgendeine person
die ein musikvideo sinkt und das ist
echt unfassbar von den ganzen videos oft
die ich jetzt reagiert haben ist geführt
die hälfte von jakob sartorius
an der stelle wird das heutige wird
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich habe noch nie eine
trainerstelle gemacht deswegen dachte
ich mir hey lade ich das einfach mal
hoch wenn es euch gefallen hat las man
lässig eine zweite trainer to print
challenge machen sollen noch mal auf so
etwas reagieren soll dann schaffen wir
60.000 freunde
das ist eine hohe zahl aber wenn ich das
noch mal machen soll dann schafft ihr
das und sonst würde ich jetzt einfach
nur noch sagen